all right let's bring in brian kill me
co-host of fox and friends and host of
one nation with brian kilmeade already
off to a great start brian great to see
you thanks for being here we are waiting
to see the press briefing is happening
shortly at the white house and i don't
know we don't have a seat in the room
they're still on covid protocol so
there's you know not all the reporters
can be in the room at one time
um so she might not even get a question
on this but certainly it should be
followed up
sandra a couple of things any time there
is an opportunity to do a poll about
what matters most to the american people
you know it's number one and number two
inflation and crime you're just flipping
back and forth depending on how bad the
numbers are with your business
background i know you zero in on that
the other thing is beyond a shadow of a
doubt 22 major cities sees a significant
rise in gun assaults aggravated assaults
domestic violence uh and uh and
homicides across the country okay so we
have identified there is a huge problem
do we all agree on that then the
question is what are you doing about it
and the question is what does president
biden do about it it's true he doesn't
say defund the police but what does he
say really since the 1990s he's not
really been tough on crime since bill
clinton was in the office he has not
been tough on crime it's so easy to go
back and say well crime was rising under
president trump true but is there anyone
including his bravest critics who didn't
think that trump wanted to crack down on
crime but he's not the mayor he's not
the police chief in seattle he is not
the mayor of chicago he doesn't do
anything in portland he can't control
new york city what he can do is say what
do you need i could give you federal
troops i can give you federal aid and
what did he do he jettisoned them in in
seattle and immediately they were pushed
back by the democratic mayor this
president has an opportunity an
opportunity to save what would be left
of a decent 2022 election when he
appears with eric adams on thursday talk
about i want to pressure the democratic
legislature the democratic city council
to get rid of no cash bail i want them
to pressure these da's who are
embarrassing this country garcon and
others uh cha the chesa bodine over in
san francisco alvin bragg who promises
to destroy new york city on their
horrible philosophies they're allowing
crime to go rampant
chester bodine actually ran sandra on
the premise i will not crack down on
quality of life crimes great now they
have no quality of life in san francisco
is that your goal so the question is not
what he thinks it's what he does not
what he says on what actions you will
take against your own party shoplifters
paradise uh there in san francisco can
walk out of a store with
something and not face any consequences
for it uh all right so these are jen
saki's words want to make sure that we
put them out there because she was asked
about it in the briefing yesterday but
this is the podcast where she seemingly
laughed off
fox's coverage of the crime crisis
and then on fox is janine pirro talking
about soft on prime consequences i mean
what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage what's scary about it is a
lot of people watch that
there that's a very real thing soft on
crime consequences i mean look at these
great american cities that are being
destroyed by it and by the way you don't
have to
just watch here to to know that that's a
problem i mean you can ask those polled
that are extremely or very concerned
about higher u.s crime rates it's at 81
percent brian i don't think you can get
there by just watching tv coverage of it
this is something that people are
feeling every single day when they walk
around their city in towns
couple of things when she says a lot of
people watch this how about almost every
news viewer is watching us and if you
take all those other ratings and pour
them together they still don't they
don't still amount to people who watch
sandra smith and today trace gallagher
and i'll go drill down on one of her
points it is well i put money aside in
the bill in the rescue plan back in
march on the 1.9 trillion there was 350
million put aside for cops right but
those cop that money could you hang on
can you hang on live to the briefing
room she's being asked about it right
now
and the attorney general will join with
law enforcement officials alongside
elected leaders including mayor adams
governor hochul at the new york police
department headquarters to discuss the
work that federal state and local law
enforcement officials are doing to
quickly take guns
and repeat shooters off of our streets
afterward president biden attorney
general garland mayor adams governor
hochul and other elected leaders will
visit with community violence
intervention leader leaders in queens to
talk about the community-led work to
interrupt gun violence the president
outlined a comprehensive plan last year
to tackle gun crime that includes giving
cities historic funding through the
american rescue plan to put more cops on
the beat and support community violence
intervention programs as well as
initiatives like after school
programming creating economic
opportunities and reducing recidivism to
address the root causes of gun crime the
president's budget also doubles federal
support for community policing with 300
million dollars more for cities plus
another 200 million dollars for
community violence interventions a total
of a half a billion dollars for these
strategies that are proven to reduce gun
crime he's going to continue to urge
congress to act on that
finally the department of justice
continues to step up their efforts to
combat violent crime and gun trafficking
including through five strike forces
launched last year in new york city and
other regions as the department of
justice reported just last week those
efforts have resulted in thousands of
guns and violent criminals being taken
off the streets over the past year but
they will of course have more to say on
thursday why don't you kick us off it's
been a busy news day so we have a few um
off the top senator manchin just said uh
bill back better is dead all right there
you have it uh trace she actually did
make a statement right off the top there
she had not started her q a
that she came out with a prepared
statement and we did know the president
was planning to travel to new york this
week they announced that last week
giving further details she'll he'll be
traveling here with a.g garland meeting
with local leaders on the ground
including mayor adams of new york city
uh she also talked about the allocation
of funds that we were just talking to
brian kilmeade about uh to the police um
so that was i i would take it as a
response or a follow-up on to what we
heard from her yesterday yeah but you
know it's what she didn't say it's also
important there because she has been
criticized for not really going after
these soft on prime uh crime prosecutors
across the country they repeatedly go
after guns the gun problem the guns the
guns and say nothing about the people
who are firing those guns who are back
on the street because of these soft on
crime policies in san francisco los
angeles philadelphia new york etc and
that's kind of where people are wanting
this administration to at least
acknowledge that there's a problem out
there uh brian kilmeade's still with us
brian uh thank you for staying with us
your reaction to what you just heard
from saki number one it shows that it
matters that that station that horrible
station what does that even mean you led
with the stats that were we were
questioning all day and all morning long
so we do matter number two is what will
he do besides meet with his favorite
mayor according to that mayor mayor eric
adams what will he do besides that he
has got to turn around to the democratic
governor and said no cash bail is not
working he's got to turn around those
legislators you democrats and say find a
way to crack down on crime and back
these people up until that it's just
words and the american people not
democrats or republicans are not going
to tolerate their lives being destroyed
and sitting there watching their rite
aids being looted it's not gonna work
what do they not understand about this
this is not working it's not an opinion
it's not a tax cut or a tax increase
this is right and wrong it's not right
and left i i i'm flabbergasted that they
don't realize this even for their only
poli even if it's only for their
political benefit and by the way she
also is issuing that statement and
reminding everyone that biden's coming
to new york after the president of the
fraternal order of police came out with
a very strong condemnation of what he
said was
her the appearance that she was laughing
off crime being a real issue in this
country
he said she may feel safe in the white
house one of the most protected
buildings in the u.s but not everyone
feels safe in their workplace he said we
the world we find ourselves in is
dangerous and becoming increasingly more
so real quick final brian my final
thought about is this there's going to
be another officer buried on wednesday
why are you coming thursday mr president
come wednesday why did you go see a
broken bridge on friday go to st
patrick's on friday then we won't care
about what your policies are we'll know
where your heart is that was that's what
the american people would respond to and
if he saw what we saw last week there
wouldn't be any giggling when the word
when the word crime came up on our
station or when janet bureau spoke
because she happens to be a law and
order judge
it's a real crisis and it's one that's
driving a lot of business out of this
city um small businesses are having a
hard time staying open they can't even
call the police and have them show up in
some cases the police are so inundated
with calls and we have less of them and
by the way you've got major bank ceos
saying that it's tough to recruit people
to work in the city it's tough to get
people back from work from home back to
the city not because of covid they're
having a hard time because people say
they don't feel safe on public
transportation and working and walking
down the streets in new york city i'm
sure you're going to be talking about
that on your new hit show one nation
saturday's 8 p.m brian kilmade go get
him sandra thank you okay give my best
to trace thank you brian
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else